People really like you, you know, they really do, I--
That's nice.
No, I believe that.
(audience applauding)
You are.
Thank you.
The crowd, there was a pause there
'cause the crowd didn't agree immediately.
But then they got the idea.
They were like.
[Both] Okay.
(clapping)
He seems to need this.
Yeah.
No, you are, you know they, you've been so many,
funny in so many different shows.
Veep, you get to be absolutely hilarious.
Oh, man, well they allow me to be, like,
work with Julia and all that, they're great.
Yeah, you know, one thing I was thinking about today
is that your work on HBO, HBO is, I think,
killin' it these days, so many great shows.
Do you love, are you a Game of Thrones fan?
'Cause I love Game of Thrones.
Do you?
Yeah.
Okay.
What do you mean, do I?
I think every person alive loves Game of Thrones.
I know, I know, do you guys like Game of Thrones?
(audience applauding)
Okay, okay, simmer down, simmer down.
Here's my thing, I tried it, I gave it a shot.
I sat down with my wife to watch the first episode.
And then they pushed a kid out the window
in the first episode.
And I was like, I'm out, I can't do that.
That's when I was in.
(Tony and audience laughing)
'Cause see, if you've been around kids long enough,
you know, every now and then,
a kid needs a little shove out a window.
Especially when it makes 'em psychic.
(laughing)
But that's the thing, they ask me, like,
so what stopped you?
And I told 'em, well, that kind of was upsetting.
Children in peril.
You're a very sensitive guy.
Yes.
But they asked me why, and I was like,
because they pushed, you mean, they pushed
a kid out the second-story window, that's intense.
Yeah, second story's not that high.
But then, but then, but then they said,
oh, well, that's not the worst of it.
And I was like, well, my God.
And then they told me what else happens,
and I was like, I'm out, I'm not doin' that.
Oh, it is, I mean--
It gets intense from they told me.
I haven't seen it, but I've heard it's pretty crass.
Yeah, well--
Crass,
that sounds like a 40s word.
Yeah, yeah.
You know what, it's crass!
It's too crass for me!
I won't watch it, I tell you, I won't!
(audience laughing)
I'm gonna stick you in my pot of islet.
It's fantastic, it's riveting, that show.
You're wrong, you're a fool.
No, here's, I know, I know it's a good show,
but it's a lot, it's a lot to watch.
It's very, it makes me anxious.
Makes you anxious to see people get hurt
even if it's pretend?
Yeah.
You know it's pretend.
'Cause they're, well there's so much going on in the world
there's so much fear, there's some anxiety.
I don't know if I wanna watch,
I mean I can bare,
I can barely watch the Office, it makes me anxious.
'Cause like--
The Office?
You can't watch the Office in reruns?
Well there's, there's a part of me that I'm like,
just like, just fire the guy.
Just like, get him, get out of the office.
(audience laughing and applauding)
He's a lot to work with.
You can't handle the tension.
Okay, what about, uh,
I think you mentioned to me once that you can't handle
even creepy music.
You told me, we were having a conversation once,
you said, eerie music, you can't handle it.
Like, eerie music in what, a scary film?
Yeah, but who can?
I mean that's--
Everybody, those are popular movies.
That's what I don't get.
And I'm genuinely serious.
Are we at a hoedown, I didn't know that.
(audience laughing)
That is crass.
No, I, well I just, again, there's so,
I mean, good God, if you wanna be afraid,
just grab some popcorn and watch CNN.
[Carson] Yeah.
You know it's, it's crazy.
So do you just watch Hallmark?
Yeah, What do you watch?
I mean--
What do you watch?
Eggo waffle commercials?
(audience laughing)
This Eggo sure is good.
Do you have any shows where people are nice to each other
and nothing really happens?
Well I watch a lot of YouTube.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, no one gets hurt on YouTube.
(audience laughing)
No, but I like all of those--
You wanna see some people get, you watch,
half the YouTube videos someone's getting pushed
out a window.
Okay, that you watch.
I watch like the babies laughing.
I like those compilation videos of--
That's creepy.
No, no, no.
I don't wanna see babies laughing.
You know like on X Factor and the voice where they,
but I only like to see them winning,
I don't wanna see them rejected.
I'm like, you can't--
Come on.
What do you do when you see a flower that's stating die?
(laughing)
Do you run away?
(screaming)
I won't like it, I only wanna see this right here.
Yeah, well thank God for plastic.
(audience laughing)